yeah but one second increment is very
deceiving it's hard to gain time and
then when you're below five seconds even
simple positions can be difficult okay
so I'm I have a streak I have three wins
in a row and I'm playing Carlsen okay
focus let's pretend I'm not playing
Carlsen let's just play normal moves and
control the center and develop my pieces
good thing he's thinking Dutch I think
I'll just play a London system I have to
stick with what I know
like g6 I forgot about let's play Bishop
bath floor is not a good move Bishop g5
my justifier than anyway I think I'll
play this I don't want to now slip
remove anything so I gave away the
bishop hair but I have an e file I have
my Knights developed I'm slightly ahead
and development can go crazy like a four
let's go crazy because Carlsen likes
boring dry slightly better end games I
want to make this spicy maybe 95
and we could trade Bishop's this night's
tied down to defending upon so I might
consider it moves like Knight h5 do I
accept triple pawns probably not
let's move the knight back to where it
came from and maybe Queen here just
controlling the center a good Castle
kingside Suton I probably will Castle
kingside
and try and like blow open the Queen
side
Queen d6 I don't see the threat oh maybe
he just wants to castle - yep
we see three trying to be solid
I like the pair of knights slightly
closed position play rook e1 probably
just put the rooks in the center b5
interesting move it's taken play rookie
- yeah the B file maybe I should put my
knight back on d3 at queen or night C 4
and C 4 start with this no okay it's
slightly passive but my knight on d3
makes me feel safe another Knight should
maneuver probably to f3 Knight F 192
could always throw in g3 I'm probably
not necessary
Wow g5 what a move so there could be
some potential attack which means I
might actually sack up on here takes so
the ship opening up could be a problem
yeah I know sack up on and probably just
get a Knight to e5 but which Knights
maybe the snakes
King h1 let's play rugby one over defend
the pawn want to take on that floor at
some point
perché eight I have ripped e1 it's
looking a little bit scary this move so
you're gonna play Knight g3 and guys
survive over there okay the one second
increment time scramble time
so just play fast and pray attack the
Akon win the a pawn don't need me
tap the deep on trade rooks take an e
pawn so nervous let's take this up upon
maybe kind of don't back right meet me
check
I want a fork what's that move stock 1 h
5g 1
this was so scary and up at night
we're not six clean up when I take it
good try good try
we're enough one very sneaky I did it
okay not to turn it that was chess960
but that's still a win okay
to calm down
I still have tea I was really
nerve-racking I started another game
okay that's going on YouTube though
definitely